The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN: So
today we're going
to talk about Bayesian prior
estimation and prior estimation
in general.
So the last time we were
writing down the expressions
for the probability of observing
a mean measurement if you
know what the model is.
So let's try to do that again.
So suppose I have a model
that predicts some observable
and it depends on
some knobs, and it
depends on some parameters.
And suppose because I
have great powers of faith
that I believe this model is
100% correct with every core
of my being.
And also because I have
tremendous confidence in all
the people who
built my apparatus,
and the knobs that I
turn actually correspond
to the real values, and I
have tremendous confidence
in all the literature that
reports the parameter values.
And so I'm absolutely certain
that this is the truth.
So we'll start from a position
of absolute certainty,
and then we'll degrade into
doubt as the collector goes on.
So let's start from
the position of someone
who has absolute faith
that this is the truth.
Is true.
So I have a model, I
really believe this model.
So for example, I
believe that the kilogram
weight in the SI
Institute in Paris
weighs exactly one kilogram.
I believe that with
every core of my being.
I'm completely confident
that model is correct.
So there are some things
I'm really confident on.
That's one.
And maybe guys have some
things you really believe, too.
So let's go with things
we really believe.
So I plan to conduct
some experiments that
measure this observable and
are related to this model.
And so I'm going to do 10
repeats of measuring y.
So I'm going to get to the
kilogram blob that's in Paris,
and I'm going to stick it
on my really expensive scale
that I really believe
is great, and I'm
going to measure its weight.
And then I'm going to
put it back, and then
put it back, and put it
back, and put it back.
And I'm going to get another
really great scale that I
really believe is great, and I'm
going to measure it there, too.
So I've got a lot of
repeats of measuring
the weight of this
kilogram, and I
believe it's really a kilogram.
But the stupid measurements
don't say a kilogram.
They say, you know, 1.0003,
0.99995, all kinds of numbers
not equal to one kilogram.
So now I'm going to
try to figure out
what the probability is
that it would have measured
some particular value y.
So what is the probability
that my experimental
is between some value,
say, y and y plus dy.
So that's a question for you.
So what's the probability?
Sorry, what?
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so we think that
the probability that y
is in this interval given
that the model is true.
And I know the theta
values perfectly,
and I know the x
is equal to some
integral of what?
The bounds integral, probably
y to y plus dy, believe that?
What's the integrand?
Sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: The probability
[INAUDIBLE] AC function of y.
WILLIAM GREEN:
Right, so what is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You wrote it down
last time, I think.
So this [INAUDIBLE] is large?
Standard normal, right?
So it should be one
over sigma root of 2 pi.
Does that sound OK?
I mean here.
It's probably the
same, it's fine.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: What
does that notation
mean, if your model is true?
WILLIAM GREEN: So this means,
given that the model is true,
and I know these data values
are exactly certain numbers,
and the x values are actually
certain numbers, what's
the probability
that I would make
a measurement whose average
would fall in this interval?
So this line means
given that this is true,
what's the probability of that?
OK, is this right?
Is this surprising?
This is OK?
So this is what I mean.
So we say that our probability
distribution converges
to a Gaussian distribution,
this is what we expect.
So we expect it to
have been large enough
for this to be true.
Yeah?
This is very important.
This is like the whole
course, actually.
This is the whole section,
is this one equation.
So I just wanted to make sure
you really get what this says.
And if you don't
like the integral,
you can make dy really
small, and then it's
just this times dy.
OK?
Actually, this notation's
like [INAUDIBLE] I
think I should do this way.
I should do this.
This is a number.
Let's get rid of the integral.
Let's make dy really small.
I'll make it [INAUDIBLE].
That all right?
So this is the probability
density that we would observe,
this is the experimental value
y that we observe from the mean,
and this is the little with
of our tiny little interval.
Is that all right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is sigma
the [INAUDIBLE] on there?
WILLIAM GREEN:
Ah, what is sigma?
That's a great question.
We didn't write
down what sigma was.
What is sigma?
AUDIENCE: Standard deviation?
WILLIAM GREEN: It's not the
standard deviation exactly.
Standard deviation
of the mean, right?
So there's two sigmas.
We have the sigma of
y, of the measurements,
and that's equal to average
value of y squared minus.
So we just figure that for
how many experiments we do,
we just compute the average
of y squared, the average y,
subtract them.
That's the variance.
And then sigma that I
used in that equation
there is 1 over n times sigma y.
And we call this the
variation of the mean,
it's the uncertainty
in the mean value of y.
And the central
limits theorem said
that as long as n
gets really large,
we expect that this
should converge to this.
And we talked last time
about how when n get bigger,
these averages don't really
change when it gets big.
They're just the average.
But this number declined
as n gets big because
of this one over n formula.
And to understand that,
suppose I measure the weight,
and I measure, it should
be around one kilogram.
But in fact my measurements
are all over here.
Lots of measurements.
So they have a variance
something like this.
But if I make a plot of--
as I run, I compute
the running average.
So when I run the
first two points,
I get some average value here.
After I run 27 points more,
the average value is here.
After I run 1,000 repeats,
It's getting pretty
close to this,
and the uncertainty
in this number's
getting smaller and
smaller as I'm doing
better and better averages.
The average more
and more repeats.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So from this key equation, I
can derive a lot of things.
And it depends what
you want to do.
So one thing people do a lot is
it was called model validation.
And what does this mean?
It means I have a model,
I believe it's true.
I have some parameters,
I believe they're true.
But there are some
foolish skeptics out there
who don't have the
faith that I do.
And they think that my model's
baloney, or my parameter
values are wrong, or something.
And so to prove I'm right, I'm
going to make some experiments.
And I'm going to
show that I make
a plot that looks like the
experiment and model agree.
Some of you might have done
this in your life, yes?
Everybody might make a
parity plot or something.
You've seen these things before.
Now, this is like a
confidence builder.
You're trying to get
the skeptics out there
to believe that
there's some evidence
to back up your faith that
this model is perfect.
And what you really
want to know is
like, if the measurement
that I measure,
the average for my 10,000
repeated measurements,
I expect that this quantity
should be pretty big somehow
in some way.
By then quantitatively
saying what
that means exactly what's a
good fit, what's a bad fit,
this is actually kind
of a difficult question,
and we'll come back to this one.
But that's a very common
use of this equation
is to try to do validation.
Now because it's
kind of complicated,
most people don't
actually do it.
So instead what they
do is they just plot
some data points, and they
plot your model curve.
And as long as they look
good, then you're done.
So that's the normal way that
it's done in the literature
currently.
But of course, that's
completely unquantitative.
It doesn't really say whether
the model and the data
really agree, it just means they
look sort of like each other.
So that's like a human
qualitative thing.
Now, if the purpose
of validation
is just to convince humans,
then you've done the purpose.
Now, if your purpose is to
try to quantitatively say
something, then you
really have to get
into this equation,
which usually is not done
but would be the right
thing to do for validation.
Now the alternative view
is disproving a model.
But I just say that there's
several ways this can happen.
You can try to disprove a
model, but you might also
show that the theta
values are incorrect.
Or you might show that
the experiment is wrong.
These are all
possibilities, reasons
why the model and the data
might not agree with each other.
So this equation, it only holds
if the model is really true,
if the parameter values
are all perfectly correct,
if we know exactly what all
the knob values are perfectly.
If any of those
things are not true,
then you should have
some discrepancy,
and there should be
a way to show it.
And really what
you're showing is
that you'd observed
some y that is
very unlikely to be observed.
So probably observing that
y is very extremely unlikely
if all these other
things were true.
So if all these things are true,
and you compute this value,
and this value's
very tiny, then it
makes you think that
it's unlikely that you
would have observed that.
And therefore, you might try to
use that as an argument to say
that something must be wrong.
The model's wrong, parameters
are wrong, the knobs are wrong,
something's wrong.
My y values are wrong.
It could be any of those things.
So this is often the most
exciting papers to publish.
You publish a paper, you take
some model that a lot of people
believe.
You tell them they're full of
baloney, it's completely wrong.
My great experiment shows
you are completely wrong.
And so you'll see a
lot of these in Nature.
I should warn you,
a lot of those
get retracted later, a very
high retraction rate in Nature.
Because they want
to publish papers
like that that show that the
common view is incorrect,
and sometimes it's true.
But oftentimes the common
view is actually correct,
and there's something
wrong with the experiment,
or the interpretation, or how
they computed this equation,
or whatever.
And so actually it turns out the
common view is perfectly fine,
and it's just that the foolish
authors went off on a tangent.
And then they have
to six months later
publish a retraction,
by the way, sorry,
paper was completely wrong.
And so you see a lot of that.
So that's a second
kind of thing.
And we'll talk more about
that a little bit later, too.
And then another thing is
I'll relax my assumptions.
So I'll say, well, I'm sure
that the model is true,
and I'm sure that my knob
settings are perfect,
and I know what they are.
But I'm not really sure
about all the parameters.
And therefore I want
to use the experiment
to try to refine
parameter values.
So I'm trying to take my y's
that I measure and somehow
infer something
about the thetas.
And this is a very
common thing to do.
So in my group we've tried to
measure the rate coefficient
for a reaction.
We believe there is
value of that theta,
and in fact, we probably have
an estimate of what it is.
But we're not sure
of the exact number,
and we'd like to do an
experiment to refine the number
and get it more
accurately determined.
So that's another
useful thing to do.
And this leads into two somewhat
different points of view
about this.
One you've probably done already
called least squares fitting.
That's one view.
And the other is
this Bayesian view
that I'll tell you about next.
So there's sort of
A and B. There's
one that I'll call Bayesian,
and one I'll call least squares.
They're sort of related
to each other, but not
exactly the same conceptually.
So I'll try to explain that.
So the Bayesian view
is probabilistic,
so it's actually pretty
straightforward to write down.
Remember that we wrote that
the probability of A and B
is equal to the
probability of A times
the probability of B
given A, and it's also
equal to the probability
of B times the probability
of A given B. And
what we have here is
one of these conditional
probabilities,
if the thetas have
a certain value,
this is a certain probability.
So I should be able to
use that formula somehow.
So I can write down that
the probability of measuring
y given theta is equal to
the probability of y times
the probability of
theta given y divided
by the probability of theta.
So I just took this formula,
and I plugged in y's and thetas
instead of A's and B's.
So I said, these two
are equal to each other.
Rearranged it so then
I can rewrite this.
This is the way we have
it in here, probably
of measuring y given theta.
Let's flip it around.
So probability of theta
given that we measured
y is equal to the
probability of theta times
the probability of observing
y if theta was true
divided by the probability of y.
Terrible handwriting there.
That's just algebra.
So this is what we want to know.
We want to know, what's the
probability distribution
of the parameter values y?
Because some of
them are uncertain.
Now, before we started
the experiment,
we had some idea of
what the ranges were
for all the primary values.
Like I'm trying to measure
a rate coefficient.
I know from experience with
other similar reactions,
from a quantum
chemistry calculation,
from some indirect evidence,
from some other more
complicated experiment,
I have some idea
that this rate coefficient
has to be in a certain range.
Now, it could be
pretty uncertain.
It might be five orders
of magnitude uncertain.
But I know it's not less than 0.
I know it can't be faster
than the diffusion limit, how
fast things can come together.
So for sure I know some
range, and oftentimes I
know a much narrower
range than that.
So I have some information
about these parameter values
before I even start.
Some of the parameters
of the model I
know perfectly, or pretty well.
So you know maybe there's a
Planck's constant, or the heat
of formation of one of
my chemicals or something
like that shows
up in the numbers,
and I might know that parameter
really pretty accurately.
Whereas the particular rate
coefficient I care about
is the thing I really
don't know very well.
So some of these have tight
probability distributions
ahead of time, and some
of them have loose ones.
And this thing has a name.
It's called the prior.
And it's our prior information
before we did the experiment.
And this one, after we've
done the experiment,
we're going to change it.
So we're going to
say previously people
thought that the parameters all
lied in these certain ranges.
And now I'm going
to get a tighter
range, because I have some
additional experimental
information.
So this is called the posterior.
This means before,
it means after.
So this is what I know
about parameter values
before and after the experiment.
This is the formula
that I have over there.
It's a probability that if the
thetas had a certain value,
probably would have
observed what I saw.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Which one
refers to which?
WILLIAM GREEN: Sorry,
this is the prior,
this is the posterior.
And those of you who are
paying attention to notation
realize I'm not doing
this very nicely.
Because these are
continuous variables,
and I'm writing
capital PRs, and they
should be not be capital PRs,
it should be probably density
functions instead.
So let's rewrite it nicely.
So the probability
of theta given y,
probability density is equal
to the probability density
of theta initially times the
probability of y given theta,
[INAUDIBLE] density divided by
the probability density of--
all right?
And what I just
basically did was
this is the correct equation
the previous other one was all
multiplied by d theta dy, it
shouldn't be done that way.
So this is OK?
Now this is the
prior information
I have about the
parameter values.
I know that they have to
fall into some ranges.
And really all I'm doing is I'm
correcting that information.
I'm improving the information
to tighten the distribution.
So initially I know that
my rate constant, here's
my rate constant.
I know that it's got to
be greater than zero,
and I don't think it's really
down there at zero anyway.
I think it's somewhere in here.
I really don't know much.
And I really don't think it's
all up at the diffusion limit,
and no way it's higher
than the diffusion limit.
So that's my initial
information that I
have about the probability
distribution of K.
So it's the rate
coefficient I want to know,
and I know it's
bigger than zero,
less than infinity.
And actually I know there's
some physical limit,
it can't be higher than
something or other.
And you can do this
for any problem, right?
I give you any
parameter, you should
be able to tell me
something about it.
You might be uncertain by
20 orders of magnitude,
but at least you have
an error bar some width.
It can't be anything, right?
A lot of parameters have to
be positive, for example.
You know that.
And you usually know something.
you might not think you
know anything, but you do,
you actually do know
before you start.
So you actually know, this is
the P of theta to start with.
And after I've done
the experiment,
hopefully you're going to know
more information about it.
I might know that
this quantity here
is going to be like a
Gaussian distribution.
It might have a kind of
goofball dependence on theta.
I should comment that.
Notice how theta
appears inside F.
So theta's up in the exponent.
It's sort of inside a Gaussian,
but it's like processed by F
and so the observable might have
a pretty goofball dependence
on this rate coefficient.
So this thing could
be some weird thing.
But for sure, when I change
theta so this changes a lot,
it's going to make a
pretty big difference.
Because up inside the
exponent of a Gaussian,
so it's going to drop
off a lot somewhere.
So I should get something
that looks something like this
maybe for my experiment.
So this one is P of K
initially, the prior.
This one is P of yk.
And what this equation
says is I want
to multiply those two together.
And so I'm going to
multiply this times this,
and I'm going to get
some new thing that's
something like that when
I multiply this time that.
Is that OK?
And so that's my new
numerator of this equation.
Now this denominator
doesn't make too much sense.
This says, what's
the probability
that I measured the mean
I measured, given nothing?
So this is sort of like
the prior probability
that I would have
measured it or something.
I don't know what this is.
So instead what people do,
is they say, forget this.
But instead, let's multiply
this by a constant that's
going to normalize it to
make it probability density
so that it integrates to one.
So that's the way
Bayes' theorem is used.
This is called
Bayesian analysis.
And so what it's
telling you is how
to take your experimental
information as expressed
in this formula and use all
your previous information
about the parameters,
put them all together,
now we have a cumulative
information about everything.
So we have some parameters
that came into our problem
into my experiment,
but from previous work,
I also knew something
about those parameters.
Now I put it all
together and I get
a new value of
probability distribution
of those parameters.
And if my expert
was really good,
it would make this really
tight [WHOOSHING SOUND]..
And then when I multiply
these two together,
it's going to make
this really sharp,
and we have a really
good value of k.
So that's like the
ideal case if I
have a really great,
well-designed experiment
executed perfectly with great
precision, then I can do this.
More generally, when I
don't think about it,
I get some
distribution like this.
I still learn something
compared to what I had before,
but it might not be much.
So now I can end up with
some distribution that's
a little tighter than before.
So is this OK so far?
All right, now this
is super simple.
I didn't have to
solve anything, all
I had to do was multiply
two distributions together.
So in some respects, this is
what you should always do.
All you do is you
take your experiment,
you multiply the probability
distribution corresponds
to your experiment
times the prior,
and you get some posterior,
and that's why new information
about the distribution.
And if I have a
distribution like this,
suppose this is my
new distribution here,
I can still get it central
value, that's my mean value, k.
I can get an estimate
of the range of k.
So I end up with
a k plus or minus
dk maybe, from just
looking at the plot.
In fact, I never even have to
evaluate what this constant is
in order to do this.
I can just go look at the
plot, see where the peak is,
figure out the width,
and I can report now
because in my experiment,
k plus or minus
dk is more precisely
determined than it was before.
Now, a practical
challenge with this
is that theta is usually
a lot of parameters.
And I only drew the plot
here in one dimension,
but really it's a
multi-dimensional plot.
So really what looked like,
suppose I had two parameters.
I had my k I care about, and
I have some other parameter,
theta 2, that also it
shows up in my model.
And say, before
I started, I knew
theta 2 fell in
this kind of range,
and I knew k fell in
this kind of range.
So really before I started,
if I think what it looks like,
I really had sort of a
blobby rectangular contour
plot, where I think it's
more likely that the k
value and the theta 2 value
are somewhere in this range.
And the most likely one is maybe
somewhere in the middle there.
But I really didn't know much.
So it could be anywhere
in this whole blob.
Now, when I do the experiment,
the experimental value
depends of both k and theta 2.
And commonly what'll happen
is that the distribution
from the experiment--
need color chalk here.
Let's get rid of these guys.
So this is my probably
distribution, there's my prior.
If I do the experiment, maybe
I'll have something like this.
That the experiment
says that the guys
have to be somewhere in
the contour plot like this.
Because I can get
pretty good fits
of the data with
different values of k
as long as I compensate
with the value theta 2.
Now I multiply these two
dimensional functions.
The original is a blob
function, and this
is a stretched out blob.
And I multiply a stretched
out blob times a fat blob,
I get some stretched
out blob that
looks something like the
intersection of these guys.
And so I end up with some
kind of blob like that.
I'll draw it really thick.
So this is my posterior,
some kind of blob like this.
So now I know a little bit
more about these two parameters
than I did before I started
because of my experiment.
Is this OK?
I really can't say I know
what the real value of k
is, or the value of theta 2.
But I know that
combinations of k
and theta 2 that are sort of
in this range, all of them
will give me pretty
good fits to my data,
and also be consistent with all
the previous information I have
about those parameter values.
Is that all right?
Now, I drew it with
two parameters.
In a lot of models we have,
we have five parameters,
six parameters, seven
parameters, nine parameters,
14 parameters.
We have a lot of parameters.
And so then we try to
make this plot, even how
to display the plot is going
to be a little problematic.
But it's there, right?
And somehow, we still
narrowed down the hypervolume
in the parameter
space from whatever
it was to begin
with to now we know
something a little bit better.
We have a narrower range
of the parameters that
would be consistent with all
the information available,
including my new experiment.
And then the next guy
does his experiment,
and he does an experiment that
shows that these guys have
to be somewhere in this
range in order to be
consistent with his experiment.
And so now I can
narrow down the range
to be something like that.
And the next person
does their experiment,
and they get something
else, and something else,
and something else.
And eventually by 2050, we have
a pretty nice determination
of the parameter values.
So that's the
advance of science,
as drawn in chalk by
Professor Green at the board.
So this is a very
important way to think
about it, is what you're
doing when you do experiments,
is you're generally restricting
the range of parameter space
that's still consistent
with everything.
And when we mean
consistent, we mean
that the probability that you
would have observed what you
did observe is reasonably high.
We'll still have to come back
to quantitatively figure out
what reasonably high means.
Now, when you did this
before when you were kids,
nobody mentioned the
word Bayes, or Bayesian,
or conditional
probabilities, right?
So they just said, oh, just
do a least squares fit.
How many of you did that before?
So somebody told me
before, forget this stuff,
we're going to never
even mention this stuff.
We're just going to do
a least squares fit.
Now, where did the least
squares fit idea came from?
It came from looking at
this formula and saying,
you know, this is the deviations
between the experiment
and the model prediction,
and I weigh them somehow,
and I have the square.
And that's the thing
I want to make small.
If I have a high probability
that what I observed really
happened, or the probably
I'm going to observe this,
it's got to be that
these guys have to be
reasonably close to each other.
They're really different.
And it's going to be
very small, because it's
inside an exponential.
And if those guys
are really different,
and the squared thing
is really large,
then the probability
is incredibly small
that I would have observed that.
So we think that this
thing should be small.
And in fact, if I want to get
the very best fit I can get,
which means like the probability
was the highest of what
I observed in the real
observation or something,
then if I'm free to adjust
one of these thetas,
I can adjust the
theta, try to make
this thing like equal to
zero, or small as I can.
So that's where the concept
of least squares comes from.
Now, when you're
doing least squares,
you almost always have
multiple parameters,
and therefore you're going to
have to have multiple data.
And they can't just be
a repeat of one number.
Can't be your data, it's
not sufficient to determine
the parameters.
So normally when you
do an experiment,
you have to change the knobs.
We have to make measurements in
a couple different conditions.
Like for example, kinetics.
You often want the Arrhenius
A factor and the EA.
And so I got to
run the experiment
in more than one temperature
or I'm never going
to be able to figure that out.
So I have to change the
temperature in my reactor.
Make some measurements
at one temperature,
and make some measurements
at a different temperature.
And for almost everything in
life that you want to measure,
you're going to have to do this.
You vary the concentration
of your enzyme
if you want to see how the
enzyme kinetics depends
on something. you
can't just keep
running exactly the same
condition over and over.
You'll get that
number really precise,
but it's not enough
information to really fill out
the parameters in your model.
So you're going to have to run
several different experiments
with different knob settings.
Also, normally we don't just
measure one quantity, one
observable in each experiment.
We usually try to measure
as many things as we can.
So we actually have
several observables
at each knob setting, and we
have several knob settings,
so we have quite a lot of data.
And each one of those is
repeated a whole bunch of times
so that we're confident that we
can use this Gaussian formula.
And so what we really have is
the pi-th observable measured
at the l-th knob position.
Well, I'm sorry,
l's not good either,
it's used in your notes
for something else.
M, there you go.
The m-th knob position.
Now, normally you have several
knobs, so that's a factor.
And we have a lot of observables
we can make at each position.
So this thing is a measurement.
And we repeated this multiple
times so I can get the average.
And we're also going to have a
corresponding sigma I M, which
is the variance of the mean.
So it's variance, that's
going to be divided
by the square root of
the number of repeats
for that particular experiment
and that particular observable.
So this is your
incoming data set,
and you also have your model
which predicts y model,
it predicts the observable i for
the sequel to fi of xk theta.
So if you have
certain knob settings,
like certain temperature, and
you have your parameter values,
then you can calculate
what the model thinks
should be the observable
value, and then you
can actually measure it
and measure its variance.
so that's the normal situation.
And now you want to figure
out, are there some values
of the theta that make the
model and the data agree?
And that's the least
squares fitting thing.
So what we can define
as a new quantity,
weight of the residual vector
EJ, which is defined to be jk,
to be consistent with
Joe Scott's notes.
AUDIENCE: Is k the same as m?
WILLIAM GREEN: M
is in oppositions,
I'll tell you what
k is in a second.
m, sorry.
Too many indices.
OK, so this is the residual
between the model position.
And now-- oh man, I'm
sorry, [INAUDIBLE]..
K is an index over i and m.
So k is just going to
list all the data you got.
Some of the data came from
the same knob settings,
some came from
different knob settings.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is x the m
the y model i [INAUDIBLE]??
WILLIAM GREEN: Thank you, yes.
y model i, I guess
this is now k.
And so k is one of
these indices that
carry-- you can bind two indices
together and put them together
just like you did
in your PD problems.
All right.
Now, I wrote down this sigma.
But actually if you're
measuring multiple things
at the same
experiment, you should
expect them to be correlated.
So really what we
should worry about
is the c, the covariance matrix,
that we defined last time.
So you should also
compute that thing.
And so what you should expect
is the probability density
that we would measure
any particular residuals
if the model is true.
And if we have these
certain parameters, theta,
this should be equal to
2 pi negative k over 2
the determinant of c
negative 1.2 exponential
of negative 1/2, epsilon
transpose c inverse epsilon.
So this is the multi measurement
version of the same equation
here.
So this is the
quantity that we think
should be small if we
have good parameter values
and we did a good experiment.
Actually, even when we
did bad experiments,
still should be small if we
have good parameter values.
And that's because the c's,
if we did a bad experiment,
we'll have a high
variance or something,
then we should see the c's
will give us weightings
that will reflect that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: Is that--
AUDIENCE: So you have the next
[INAUDIBLE] K [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM GREEN: Oh I'm sorry,
this is the capital K,
this is the number
of data points.
So little k is equal
to 1 to capital K.
AUDIENCE: So does capital K
count for both experiments?
WILLIAM GREEN: It's the
number of distinct data values
after you've already
averaged over repeats.
So you do m experiments, at each
experiment you measure capital
I observables.
So it's like m times I, so
K. If you measured everything
in every experiment,
it's equal to I times m.
Now there's two ways that people
approach this in literature.
The fancy way is
you say, you know,
this covariance matrix comes
in in a pretty important way
into this probability
distribution function.
And so maybe I need to worry
a lot about whether I really
know the covariance matrix.
And my uncertainty in the
mean drops pretty fast
as I do averaging, but
I'm not so confident
that my answer in the
covariance matrix was small.
So what people do
sometimes is they'll
try to vary both c and theta,
and try to get a best fit where
they're varying c.
But then they have
additional constraints
on c that c has to satisfy the
equations you gave last time
about how you calculate the
covariance matrix from data.
And so I was saying,
well, I want this c
to personify these
equations pretty well,
but true covariance of
the world of the system
is not the same
as what I actually
measure by just measuring, say,
five repeats of an experiment.
And so I might
want to vary the c.
You try to vary the c, turns out
to be kind of complicated math,
so not many people do it.
Even though conceptually
it makes some sense,
you should worry about
the fact you're not really
sure about the covariance.
So what a lot of
people do is they say,
let's just use the c that's
computed from the formulas
I gave you last
time experimentally.
So just say, let's just take c
experimental, put them in here.
And now this is a constant.
And now the only thing
that varies in this problem
is thetas which come
into the epsilons.
Because the epsilons
depend on theta.
And so in that
case, I can just try
to maximize this probability.
And what that happens
to do is to minimize
this quantity in the exponent.
And so all I need to
do is say, for example,
theta best is equal to arg
[INAUDIBLE] theta epsilon
of theta c epsilon.
And so this is the least
squares fitting problem
that you guys have
probably done before.
And probably what
you did was you
assumed I had perfectly
uncorrelated data,
and all my errors were the same.
And so c, which is the identity
matrix, and I took it out.
Probably did that before?
Yeah, OK.
That's pretty dangerous
to do, I'd say.
What people do a lot, which is
a little bit less dangerous,
is at least say,
well, you know, when
I measure the concentration
of species x by GC,
I have an error bar
of plus or minus 5%.
And when I measure
the temperature
with my thermocouple,
I have an error bar
of plus or minus 2 degrees.
And so the variances of these
guys should be a lot different,
temperature and GC signal.
And therefore I definitely need
to weight my deviation somehow.
And it's really what
you do is you keep
the diagonal entries of this.
That's often done.
And we just forget the fact
that they might be covariant.
But if you've done
the experiments,
you actually do have
enough information
to compute this thing anyway,
so you might as well just
use the experimental value.
So this is the
least squares thing.
And let's think, what
the heck is this doing?
We're saying, all of a sudden
we grabbed all the parameters
in the model, which
might include things
like the molecular weight
of hydrogen or something.
And we can find the
very best values
that would make our data match
the experiment as best as
possible.
And in some sense,
that's great, we
know the best values and
parameters for our experiment.
But of course, if we vary the
molecular weight of hydrogen,
it's going to screw up
somebody else's experiment.
Because somebody else
did some other experiment
that depended on the
molecular weight of hydrogen,
and they had to get
some other value
to match their experiment.
So in these parameter
set, anything
I do to vary those
parameters, I got
to watch out that maybe
some of those parameters
are involved with somebody
else's model and [INAUDIBLE]
some other experiments.
And I'm not really free
to vary them all freely.
So this is the idea
from the Bayesian
of having the
prior intimation is
so you know some of the ranges
on these thetas already,
and some of them you might know
really sharp distributions,
like the molecular weight of
hydrogen. You might know that
to a lot of decimal places.
And so when people
do this, normally you
don't vary all of the thetas.
Usually what you do is
you select a set of thetas
that you feel free to vary
because they're so uncertain,
and other thetas that you think,
oh, I better not touch them.
Because if I adjust
them, I may go
to crazy values that are
inconsistent with somebody
else's experiment.
So a lot of times like
the molecular weights,
you would not touch them.
You would just say,
I got to just stick
to the recommended
values and the tables.
I'm not free to vary the
molecular weight of hydrogen,
even though if I did
it would make my data
match my experiment better.
Makes my model
and the experiment
match more precisely.
So deciding which
parameters to vary in this
is a really crucial thing.
And that's a lot
of the art of doing
this has to do with that issue.
Also, you don't have
to keep the thetas
in the form you have them.
You could do a transformation.
So you could change to, say,
W's that's equal to, say,
some matrix times the
thetas, and I could express
the equation in
terms of the W's.
So I could transform my original
representational parameters
as some other parameters.
And often times,
your experiment might
be really good at determining
some of these W's, even
if it might be incapable of
determining any of the thetas.
So you often might know
some linear combination
of parameters, or maybe
not linear combinations,
some non-linear
combination of parameters
might actually be determinable
very well from your experiment,
even though you can't
determine things separately.
And this gets into the idea
of dimensionless numbers.
So your experiment might depend
on some dimensionless number
very sensitively.
And you can be quite confident
from your external data
what the value of that
dimensionless number must be.
But if you look inside
the dimensionless number,
it depends on a lot
of different things.
And you might not have
any information about them
separately.
All you know is about
your experiment just
tells you the value of that
one parameter very accurately.
So this is another
big part of the art
of doing the model
versus data is setting up
your model in terms of
parameters that you really
can determine, and getting
out all the ones you can't
determine and fixing them.
So we're really going
to generally change do
this kind of thing.
But we're going to say
that some thetas are fixed,
and also we might change to
a different representation,
change to W's instead.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
where this transform--
I don't really know
what's up with--
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah,
let's get an example.
Suppose I was doing a reactor
that had A equilibrium of B.
And I was really
interested in kf,
the forward rate for A going
to B. I'm a kineticist,
I love to know A
goes to B. However,
if I setup the
experiment wrong, it
might be that this readction
ran all the way to equilibrium.
And what I see in the
products is actually
just the equilibrium
ratio of A to B.
So what I'm measuring might
be something that's dependent
really on kf over kr, and
that might be the quantity
I can really determine.
Because that's
equilibrium constant.
If I didn't think
about it, I could just
try to have the model fitting
procedure, just optimize
to find the very
best value of kf.
And in that situation, it
might have a lot of trouble,
because it might be
quite indeterminant what
the kf is, because really all
that matters is the ratio.
Also I think about
this some more,
suppose I run at
short times, and I
measure the time dependence.
What I'm really
measuring is kf plus kr.
Do you remember we
did the analysis of A
goes to B, one of the
early homework problems?
The time cost was actually kf
plus kr, not kf separately.
And so if I measure
the exponential decay
time constant, I'm really
determining kf plus kr,
I might be able to
determine that very well.
Actually, in my lab, I can
do a great job for this.
I have an instrument
that can measure
the time constant of
the exponential of k
really precisely, but
it's determining the sum.
It's not determining either
one of them separately.
And I might have to do
a separate experiment,
say a thermo-experiment
to get the ratio.
And then from the two I can put
them together and get the two
values distinctly.
So this will be
an example of this
would be a W. My W is kf plus
kr, the matrix would be 1001,
something like that.
1-1, something like that.
Where I add these
two guys, kf, kr.
These are my two
parameters, 1 plus 1.
And I can determine W1
now very accurately.
sorry, this is m, this is W.
So now in terms of W, this has
two parameters now, W1 and W2.
I can't determine W2
from my experiment,
but I can determine
W1 really well.
So then when I do the
least squares fitting,
I should vary W1.
I can fix it it for
my experimental data,
and just leave W2
fixed at some value.
I can't do anything about it.
That all right?
Now, do you get the difference
in these two points of view?
This is like, two
completely different ways
to look at the problem.
You can think about it
as, these parameters are
free for me to vary,
and I just have
to be careful to select the
ones I'm really free to vary.
And that's the least squares
fitting point of view.
Or I could say, I'm not
really determining anything
in particular, all I'm doing
is taking the whole range
of uncertainty that we
have about parameters,
and by my experiment, I narrowed
it down in the Bayesian view.
So it's the two
different points of view.
To do this one, I need to
make sure I have enough data
to determine something.
So I have to have
enough determine
some parameter, at
least one, otherwise
there's no point in doing this.
This one I can do even if
I can't determine anything,
because I could still narrow
down the range of parameters.
But this might be harder
to report in a table.
Because all I have at the end is
a new probably density function
of multiple parameters.
All right?
OK, we're done.
See you guys on Friday.